earlier when you talked about
criminality and creativity trends in
that in men peaking at 14 it reminded me
of something you said I think it was Joe
Rogan talking about sjw's and kind of
and how they create their own chaos
talking about how adolescents have this
drive to change the world and I was
wondering if if those three the
criminality creativity drive to change
the world are linked and if so if they
manifest differently in men and women
and if they kind of come from the same
era I think they are linked but I'm
going to concentrate more on the net
second part of your question so I'm
going to ask you guys some think about
something so I talked to a friend of
mine the other day he's a very very
smart guy and we've been talking about
all all the sorts of things that we've
been talking about tonight for a long
time and we were talking about the
relatively relative evolutionary roles
of men and women this is speculative
obviously and and because our research
did indicate its tentative research so
far that that the the SGS SJW sort of
equality above all else
philosophy is more prevalent among women
well it's predicted by the personality
factors that are more common among women
so agreeable this and high negative
emotion primarily agreeableness but in
addition it's also predicted by being
female and that's interesting because in
most of the personality research that
I've done and as far as I know in the
literature at you know in more broadly
speaking most of the time you can get
rid of the attitudinal differences
between men and women or at least reduce
them by controlling for personality so
if you take a feminine man and a
masculine woman then you know that the
polls reverse but that didn't seem to be
the case with political correctness and
so I've been thinking about that a lot
because well men are bailing out of the
humanities like mad and pretty much out
of the universities except for stem the
women are moving in like mad and they're
also moving into the political sphere
like mad and this is new right we've
never had this happen before and we do
know know do not know what the
significance of it is it's only 50 years
old and so we were thinking about this
and so I don't know what do you think
about this proposition but imagine that
that that historically speaking
it's something like women were
responsible for distribution and men
were responsible for production
something like that and maybe maybe
that's only the case really in the tight
confines of the immediate family but
that doesn't matter because that's most
of the evolutionary landscape for human
beings anyways what the women does it
did was make sure that everybody got
enough okay and that seems to me to be
one of the things that's driving at
least in part the SJW demand for for
equity and equality it's like let's make
sure everybody has enough it's like both
look fair enough you know I mean you
can't you can't argue with that
but there's there's an intimacy between
that and the reality of differential
productivity you know because people
really do differ in their productivity
so alright so to answer your question
fully I do think that the rebellious
tendency of adolescents is associated
both with that criminality spike
especially among men and with creativity
yes I think that the SJW phenomena is
different and I think it is associated
at least in part with the rise of women
to political power and and we don't know
what women are like when they have
political power because they've never
had it I mean there's been queens
obviously and that sort of thing there's
been female authority figures and
females have wielded far more power
historically than feminists generally
like to admit but this is a different
thing and we don't know what a truly
female political philosophy would be
like but it might be especially if it's
not been well examined and it isn't very
sophisticated conceptually it could
easily be let's make sure things have
distributed equally well yeah but sorry
that's just not going to do you fly do
you think in terms of the rest of the
sjw's and you talked about last lecture
as well creating chaos when there is
none otherwise it'd be static do you
think there would be any validity in
saying that in a country like Canada
were pretty gender equal is there any
merit to thinking sjw's are trying to
create chaos even when they're arguably
is none on the mass level obviously
there's still problems why would they do
that otherwise it would be static and
that well that if it wouldn't them so I
read this I read this quote once and I
don't remember
who who said it it might have been
Robert Heinlein for crying out loud
science fiction author that springs to
mind but a problem it probably wasn't
and his the proposition was that men
tested ideas and that women tested men
and I kind of like that there's
something about that you know and now it
obviously it's an overgeneralization but
we also don't know to what degree women
test men sheerly through provocation
it's a lot because like if you want to
test someone you don't have a like
little conversation with them like you
poked the hell out of them and you say
okay like I'm going to let go after you
and see where your weak spots are and it
seems to me that this it seems to me
that in this constant protest and use of
shame and all of that that goes along
with this with this sort of radical
movement towards egalitarianism that
there's a tremendous amount of
provocation and god I'm going to say
this too even though I shouldn't but it
but even higher I don't believe this but
I'm trying trying to figure it out you
know I thought it was absolutely comical
when fifty Shades of Grey came out they
that just I just thought that was just
so insanely comical that at the same
time there's this massive political
demand for like radical equality and and
is and say with regards to sexual
behavior and the fastest-selling novel
the world had ever seen was S&M
domination right it's like oh well we
know where the unconscious is going with
that one don't wait and and sometimes I
think like because one of the things
that I've really tried to puzzle out and
it's not like I believe this right I'm
just telling you what I where the edges
of my thinking have been going is that
you have this crazy alliance between the
feminists and the radical Islamist that
I just do not get it's like the
feminists it's like why they aren't
protesting non-stop about Saudi Arabia
is just completely beyond me like I do
not understand it in the least and I
wonder - I just wonder bloody well is
this is the Freudian me it's like is
there an attraction you know the is
there an attraction that's emerging
among the female radicals for that
totalitarian male dominance that they've
chased out of the West and I mean that's
a hell of a thing to think but I
they're all I am psychoanalytically
minded and I do think things like that
because like I just can see no rational
reason for it the only other rational
reason is that well the West needs to
fall and so the enemy of my enemy is or
yes it's a guy exactly now what is it B
I thought that wrong with the enemy of
enemy is my friends yes exactly women
tend to vote liberal as well yes well so
that that could be the case but I am NOT
going to shape my suspicion about this
unconscious balancing because as the
demand for egalitarianism and the
eradication of masculinity accelerates
there's going to be a longing in the
unconscious for the precise opposite for
the problem of that right the more you
look you scream for equality the more
your unconscious is going to admire
dominance and so well that's that's
that's well that's how you think if your
cycle analytically minded and you know
I'm a great admirer of Freud he knew a
hell of a lot more than people like to
think and and so this is partly why
everyone still hates him even though
it's late a hundred years since he's you
know really really being around so all
right we should stop
you